contrariamente a lo que había dicho
vladimir putin de que no buscaban
ingresar a kiev estamos ante la
confirmación de que rusia quiere invadir
ucrania
sí muy buenas noches de rodrigo y creo
que en efecto los hechos más que los
discursos hoy determinan lo que se está
registrando para los libros de la
historia realmente creo que rusia ha
jugado en un segundo escenario su primer
escenario era simplemente tener una
influencia dentro de la región intentan
paz pero ya en este segundo fase que
considero que es un nuevo escenario de
parte de rusia en este lo que apunta es
no solamente derrocar al gobierno es el
insee sino creo yo en últimas lo que
quiere generar es una humillación al
presidente y mandar mensaje un sitio
bastante fuerte como ustedes bien ha
dicho excelentes que ha dado un discurso
en el que se en el que dijo que se
siente que occidente ha dejado sola a
ucrania que análisis hace de esta
conclusión a la que llegó el mandatario
sí bueno desde hace varias semanas el
occidente ya le ha mencionado al
presidente celeste que no iba a contar
con hombres si los iba a tener bastante
respaldo en términos de capacitación
militar y de armamento pero desde un
inicio occidente había mencionado que no
vio a poner hombre sin horno no puede
poner hombres en tierra porque ucrania
no es parte miembro de la otan y
claramente los países miembros no van a
arriesgarse a atan a tal atracción
porque esto podría también aumentar las
tensiones con rusia de igual manera creo
yo que es una manera prudente por parte
de occidente actuar en la medida que sí
responde de la misma manera militar
hacia rusia consideró que las tensiones
pueden escalar y la guerra puede ser
agravada y de hacerse rusia con kiev
cuáles podrían ser los siguientes pasos
de putin y qué escenario podría haber
abrirse en las relaciones
internacionales
excelente pregunta rodrigo genio en mi
opinión creo que existen tres tres
escenarios el primero es que caiga el
gobierno es el insia y el gobierno ruso
promueva un nuevo gobierno con las
fronteras ucranianas pero claramente es
el nuevo gobierno este o sea de una
inclinación más pro rusa el segundo pues
digamos que creo yo que ese es un
objetivo minimalista por parte de moscú
y eso iría en ratificar la influencia de
rusia en ucrania el segundo escenario
consideró que iría más que todo que
ucrania sea anexada por rusia y que
claramente ese tendría un objetivo
mediano en términos de lo que podría
lograr rusia en medio de esta falta de
respuesta también de occidente y el
tercer escenario que creo que es el
menos probable y espero que no suceda es
que no solamente rusia se anexe krumm y
ucrania sino que moscú decida invadir
otros países como los países bálticos
estonia letonia lituania y que aquí sí
podríamos ver una mayor agresión una
mayor respuesta por parte de occidente
porque estos países se hacen parte o son
miembros de la otan